'if the area George Freeman thank you
very much for being with it's now I mean
I only been in watan for about five
minutes when someone described it to me
has forgotten what in do you think that
had something to do with why people
voted leave in the area definitely and
and thank you for coming because Walken
feels a bit less forgotten this weekend
and yeah Walton was the first town in my
constituency to vote you Kip and it
started to agitate very early for breaks
it and I of course some of that is our
feeling about Europe and about the
unaccountability of the European
bureaucracy but it's also very clear to
me that it's a vote for change it's a
vote of legitimate grievances people
feel like walkins getting a lot of
housing and no infrastructure people see
public services under pressure because
of the austerity post-crash they see the
old main employer the bhojas pig factory
owned by a local family in the 50s and
60 is now owned by cran zurich country
foods 900 employees from Eastern Europe
and they feel as though the growth in
Cambridge is only 40 miles away might as
well be 100 years away and Walton feels
frankly as you've reported it feels
forgotten even within mid Norfolk even
within Breck land the main money from
the council goes to D remand thetford
what ins are really marginalized town do
you think politicians really understand
I mean with the government for example
really understands some of those driving
forces behind that leaf oh I yes and no
I mean I think sure reason may in that
burning in justices speech when she went
into number 10 and I went with her I
think she put her finger on some of
those real grievances that had driven
the vote for change but I think rural
voters like those that you've been to
see in my constituency this week feel
very ignored even the burning in
justices tend to be urban they tend to
be in the city there's a lot of rural
deprivation and poverty in this country
a lot of small towns that feel very cut
off and isolated and you saw what in
high streets it used to be a thriving
market town with a big RAF defense base
a factory full employment in the 50s it
was how old were mill in town you've
never had it so good now it feels like a
commuter housing estate houses being
dumped no infrastructure and that's why
I'm insisting that we have to deliver
brexit of course but much more
importantly we've got to deliver those
domestic reforms to tackle those
grievances and I just
you three which will probably resonate
having been important skills
infrastructure and aid so on skills I'm
not suggesting that we should send the
900 Eastern Europeans working in
incredibly tough and hard jobs in that
pork factory send them home and get 900
people from Walton to work there that's
not the right approach but we need to
make sure that youngsters leaving rotten
academy much better school now get some
skills and get a passport so I'm calling
for a skills passport free transport and
make sure everybody gets a chance to go
and work in the new jobs in the area on
aid a lot of people who often feel that
we're dishing money out around the world
when we should be doing more for our own
people so I'd like us to offer every
school and college levar a six-week work
experience on the front line of our aid
program like national service for its
time and on housing I just think we
should be making sure the warehousing
comes in a lot more of the money is kept
locally for infrastructure it sounds a
bit like a manifesto of your own there
you just took I mean are you worried
about you know fighting the next
election do you think at the minute
labor could win yes I do but I I don't
think it's beyond beyond recovery I just
think we need to make sure that as well
as the boring legal mechanics of brexit
I mean this is like surgery and we're
all staring at the scalpel I think we
need to be setting out a much more
positive agenda for what brexit we'll be
the catalyst for real renewal and that's
the work I'm doing this year through the
conservative Policy Forum 25
conservative colleagues and I publishing
a book this spring on renewal beyond
brexit and it's the work I'm doing
through the big tent unless we signal
that yes we're gonna deliver brexit but
it's not an extreme mandate for some you
Cape vision of Britain we're going to
deliver it as a one nation conservative
party with real renewal bold policy
reforms to tackle the grievances you've
discovered in watan then I think we'll
fail to deliver at the next election
which could be quite soon is Tories made
the right person to fight it for the
Conservatives I've made very clear my
position on that I don't think she is
well she came to the 1922 before
Christmas when threatened by the
hardline brexit ears and I supported her
as did many of us on the basis of a very
moving speech where she said listen I
will honor my commitment to see through
brexit that I will not lead you into the
next election and there was a sadness in
the room from her and it
it was a very important moment and I
honestly believe that after brexit we
ought to be choosing an election or did
she say the-- the election if she said
i'm it's it's a sadness for me that i'm
not going to lead you into the next
election and it is i can see that but
honestly i'd think that she would have
done this country a huge service
negotiating a sensible withdrawal deal
and then a new generation of
conservatives need to reach out to a new
generation of voters and frame a new
relationship with Europe and a new
vision of how we make breaks at a moment
of deep and national renewal I wonder if
there is a wider issue as well for the
Conservative Party almost an existential
issue because brexit I mean brexit has
expose divisions everywhere but it's
certainly expose divisions in the
Conservative Party and it almost feels a
real stretch to contain MPs like Sarah
Williston and Anna Subaru along with the
Jacob Riis Marx and Boris Johnson's do
you think there is a realignment of
politics going on it's a great question
I I think what you're seeing is brexit
took all the normal rules of politics
off David Cameron suspended cabinet
responsibilities collective
responsibility the whipping operation is
almost impossible the whole system has a
normal political discipline has broken
down and can you see it we've somehow
got to put back together a politics
that's capable of delivering strong and
stable government is there an alignment
a realignment going on I think there is
but it's not as big as the extremists on
either end would have you say Jeremy
Corbyn on the one hand would say yeah
there's an alignment going on the
country wants a hard left socialism I
don't think that's what's going on and
Nigel Ferrara on the right would say
others in alignment going on we want a
very right-wing nationalist narrow
shrill politics I don't think that's
what the British people want but I do
think they want a sense that Britain you
know in a world of globalization
technology big corporate power that the
Conservative Party is capable of
developing a generous one nation
compassionate but also rigorous politics
that gives people a chance in life a
chance to get on and looks after them if
they fall but it is not dishing out
money left right and center sort of
virtue signaling internationally but is
building a sense of Britain in the world
and I think that citizenship from
personal to global is a new politics you
know when I first came of age in the 80s
it was all about money trade unions
power it was all about the economy I
think politics now is about culture
ownership belonging power whether
democracy works for the people of Wotton
okay George Freeman thank you very much